cinéma avec la sortie mercredi prochain
de mookie signé par le réalisateur d'un
indien dans la ville les revêt palud à
la fiche jacques villeret eric cantona
pour une nouvelle carrière d'acteur
peut-être jacques cardoze sincère sur un
terrain de football cantona aimerait
bien le rester dans une salle de cinéma
alors lorsqu'ils se déplacent pour faire
la promotion de son film à marseille
il ne manque pas de franchise de
spontanéité et d'humour dans mon petit
cantona est un boxeur français
poursuivis par des masques
il ré lui est un moine missionnaire que
recherche des scientifiques car sa jeune
chimpanzé n'est pas comme les autres
elle parle et rit quand le sujet est
assez simple mais on se détend
sympathique agréable accents de cantona
à marseille 6 4 tout à faire ce film
mais entre andorre et mocky condor est
d'accord
ce qui m'intéresse c'est le jour jouer
prendre du plaisir
vivre des choses excitantes me sentir
vivre cette firme encore vibrer et jouer
avec les vibrations les excitations d
autres mots qui est déjà le quatrième
long métrage de cantona après le bonheur
est dans le pré elisabeth et avant les
enfants du marais qui sortira au
printemps un premier grand rôle que le
réalisateur d'un indien dans la ville
n'a pas hésité à lui confier d'accord je
voyais s'exprimer à la télévision que je
disais ccc un acteur quoi il a il a
quelque chose et ce qui ce qui
m'intéressait surtout chez lui c'était
le le côté mec très bas laissent très
fort avec une énorme sensibilité cantona
ne fonctionne qu'au rêve et à la passion
après le terrain vert et l'écran noir il
espère un jour monter sur les planches
oh